[Musique]
bonsoir j'espère qu'aujourd'hui nicolas
et pimprenelle sont sages n'en doute pas
patron je vais faire l'école ce soir et
vous savez bien que tous les enfants
aiment beaucoup les cols très bien
monsieur l'instituteur appelez moi
plutôt professeur patron je suis le
professeur nounours bon lol
bon courage professeur nounours pop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on
demande encore 20 juin au soir à la paix
non pas la poupée
[Musique]
alors nicolas tu n'as pas l'air de bonne
humeur mon bonhomme ennuis on sait pas
quand va jouer ce soir on ne joue pas au
travail
et nous on travaille bien tu sais maman
appelez moi dont professeur nounours car
vous êtes mes élèves
protestaient rnic allons mes élèves
prenez du papier de croyons
[Musique]
juste cas d'accord il suffit tout
simplement
de se conduire châtiment tombale l'îcone
on s'assied sur un bon et tout ce
qu'elle le croit et il ment pp100 comme
tout le monde est content vous pourriez
quand calais quand on veut s'amuser la
jolie aecon à la grande maison on m'a
des crayons où ils ont fait du bon
bateau où l'on chante des chansons à la
gentille école des filles et deux
garçons on le prend dix leçons on joue
avec des talons total et les créations
j'ai pu signaler je vais t'accompagner
parce que c'est à l'école
cancale et des amis des grands et des
petits
et tu trouves tu sais aussi qu on
l'aimera tout
sacrifier qui veulent l'école usait
mozilla les folies des calculs et on
rirait pour dessiner comme aimerait
beaucoup gagné
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais oui il est passible professeurs ne
nous ça à la baie de portée rihanna on a
dû faire trop de bruit pendant leur
création ce permis
d'accord patron nous allons unis ne met
pas en colère tu vois on y va
bonne nuit il marche comme ça dix ans
farani murs de notre pain et du lait
quand sera pressage la prochaine fois
bonne nuit petit frère fait pour rêve
grande soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas l'air content professeur
nounours ou alors aux eaux ils sont
heureux pour ce soir
mais ce n'était pas une vraie école
nounours c'était une école pour rire et
pour s'amuser paul furlan un patron le
professeur nounours est bien déçu ne
soyez pas tristes professeur vos petits
élèves m'ont promis d'être très sage la
prochaine fois j'espère bien bonne nuit
les petits faites de pauvres
[Musique]